we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
caller asking why won't I talk about
left-wing racism hi David
first caller I was just wondering if you
could all talk about something that
really concerning which is the racism of
the left okay yeah and it gets cut off
there tell me what left doing racism you
want me to talk about I mean listen I've
talked about comments from supposedly
lists who tweet things like I will not
vote for any whiter mail candidate in
2020 I believe that is a discriminatory
comment and I've called it out and the
person who tweeted that tried to get me
fired from my adjunct teaching position
that I had last year at Boston College
I've talked about anti-semitism on the
left so I have no problem talking about
racism on the left to the extent that it
exists and it does although it is
different and not as significant as
racism on the right but it exists and I
talk about it
but tell me exactly what racism it is
you want me to address and I will gladly
do it on today's bonus show we will talk
about an FDA warning that drinking
bleach will not cure cancer or autism
yes this is something that is spreading
in pseudo science communities we will
talk about a trump administration rule
which would penalize immigrants for
needing benefits and availing themselves
of those benefits and much much more two
ways to get access to the bonus show
number one become a member at WWJ
pakman.com number two become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show the
show doesn't have to end now because the
bonus show is coming up next if you
remember